bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 8 septembre
ridicule méprise ou acte de sabotage des
scellés d'instruction concernant
l'église de scientologie ont été
détruits à marseille
un an après la disparition de certains
éléments d'une information judiciaire
concernant aussi les scientologues
enquête sur les méthodes de cette église
considérée comme une secte pour la
première fois en france une action en
réparation est menée par la famille d'un
fumeur décédé d'un cancer contre la
cithare dernier bilan provisoire du
séisme qui a frappé hier la région
d'athènes 61 morts mais les dizaines de
personnes seraient toujours ensevelies
sous les décombres
football victoire de l'équipe de france
3 de erevan face à la roumanie mais ce
ne fut loin d'être facile pour les bleus
du cinéma c'est quoi la vie le film de
françois dupeyron avec jacques dufilho à
partir d'aujourd'hui sur les écrans
alors c'est peut être une erreur humaine
une méprise une grosse gaffe
il n'empêche l'annnonce de la
destruction de nombreux cd d'un dossier
d'instruction concernant l'église de
scientologie à marseille encourage
toutes les suspicions d'autant que les
autorités judiciaires marseillaise
viennent tout juste d'avertir les
plaignants qui intente un procès à cette
secte alors que les faits remonteraient
à la fin de l'année 98 explications ses
fans breitner avec mika d'armes en
évinçant des ombres à marseille les
avocats des parties civiles ne l'ont
appris que hier dans le bureau du
président du palais de justice
c'est la stupéfaction des scellés
relatifs au procès de la scientologie
ont été détruits parmi trois tonnes et
demi de documents des pièces comptables
des livres des électromètre religieux
vendus par la secte sont passés au pilon
est le plus surprenant c'est que
l'incident remonte à la fin de l'année
pour moi c'est une demi surprise demi
surprise que j'ai déjà eu à constater
dans d'autres affaires notamment à lyon
et à paris que les dossiers touchant
l'église de scientologie décidément de
ressembler à aucune autre et subissait
des traitements qui étaient parfois
assez étonnant à paris on perd la
procédure à marseillan détruit les
scellés au palais de justice
on parle d'une méprise
le greffe pensait que l' affaire avait
été jugée alors que le procès a lieu
dans douze jours
pourtant concernant la destruction de
pièces la justice à des règles précises
un dossier constitué par le juge
d'instruction et archivée à l'issue de
la procédure
en revanche les scellés c'est à dire les
objets les documents remis au cours de
l'instruction sont détruits mais
uniquement lorsque la procédure est
finie une affaire étrange à laquelle n'a
pas manqué de réagir le garde des sceaux
se met la disparition de pièces d'un
procès d'un événement très grave je veux
toute la vérité
est ce que c'est une erreur est ce que
c'est un sabotage et pour y voir clair
elisabeth guigou a ordonné une enquête
l'inspection générale des services
judiciaires est à marseille pour
s'assurer qu'il s'agit bien d'une erreur
aujourd'hui des pièces disparaissent à
marseille j'en déduis assez logiquement
que nam comme n'importe lequel de nos
concitoyens que l'église de scientologie
bénéficie vraiment d'un hasard heureux
et je considère qu' il ne s'agit pas là
d'une erreur voilà l'église de
scientologie dans une position
confortable en tout cas la secte affirme
rien à voir avec la destruction des
scellés on peut encore une fois allez
dire que parce que ça tombe bien c'est
étrange comme c'est bizarre ça tombe
bien oui ça tombe bien mais c'est un
hasard
ce soir dans une lettre adressée au
garde des sceaux
l'avocat des parties civiles demandent
l'ouverture d'une enquête préliminaire
décidément les palais de justice ont
trop souvent le tort de voir disparaître
les documents qui mettent en cause
l'église de scientologie
alors voilà pour les faits on en saura
donc un peu plus peut-être à l'issue
d'une enquête diligentée par la garde
des sceaux mais tout de même cette
destruction de pièces s'ajoute à la
disparition d'autres pièces d'une
information judiciaire visant elle aussi
l'église de scientologie à paris c'était
il ya un an alors on veut bien ne pas
être parano mais dans le monde politique
comme dans celui des habitués de la
lutte contre les sectes
on n'accepte pas forcément le hasard ou
les coïncidences élan dénonce plutôt le
noyautage joël bruandet et alexis
delcourt pour le reportage
sommes le 8 février 1996 à la tribune de
l'assemblée nationale alain gest
présente aux députés le rapport de la
commission parlementaire sur les sectes
en france
c'est alors qu'il aperçoit dans les
fauteuils réservés aux invités de marque
un visage qu'il connaît bien la surprise
et la mode un peu faible de constater en
rentrant dans l'hémicycle qu'il y avait
une personne qui trônait au milieu des
places réservées aux invités des
ministres et c'était donc madame du nord
la porte en lui la scientologie
un épisode parmi d'autres des relations
troubles qu'entretiennent la
scientologie et les pouvoirs on se
souvient de la disparition en octobre
dernier de plusieurs tomes du dossier
parisien
une enquête interne est toujours en
cours cette fois la destruction d'une
partie du dossier marseillais a suscité
des réactions immédiates exemple ce
communiqué des services de matignon
chargés de la lutte contre les sectes
la question se pose à nouveau dit le
communiqué de savoir si certains
services de l'état ne sont pas investis
par des organisations sectaires une
interrogation partagée par ce magistrat
qui a déjà instruit sur la scientologie
il n'y a aucune raison a priori que la
justice dans son ensemble soit épargnée
par le phénomène sectaire
il n'y a pas un secteur d'activité en
france aujourd'hui qu'ils soient
épargnés par les infiltrations sectaire
les scientologues mis-en-cause parle de
persécution et nie toute forme
d'infiltrations
ils sont les secteurs de la société
c'est certain mais de là à les accuser
de choses que n'aurait pas commis parce
qu'on n'a même pas le trouver
c'est un petit peu excessif je pense
qu'on a tort de refuser systématiquement
et il faudrait apporter des preuves
avant cette allégation
il y a trois mois le dernier rapport de
l'assemblée nationale sur l'argent des
sectes épinglait plus particulièrement
la scientologie et ses nombreuses
filiales un chiffre révélateur figurer
dans le rapport
le budget annuel de la sec en france 60
millions de francs et en effet il faut
maintenant se souvenir que dans le
rapport parlementaire sur les sectes
publié ans j'avais 96 l'église de
scientologie est classé parmi les
mouvement psychanalytique avec une forte
capacité à obtenir de ses membres des
ressources financières
portant sur les méthodes des
scientologues le commentaire des
réclamations
ce jour là les élus du peuple américain
s'apprêtait à condamner l'allemagne pour
intolérance religieuse car le
gouvernement allemand avait osé classé
la scientologie non pas comme religion
mais comme organisation commerciale
motion finalement rejetée mais voilà
bien qui illustre la considération dont
jouit cette organisation en amérique il
meuble bien placé compte en banque bien
garni acteur de cinéma scientologues
bien en vue sa puissance n'est plus à
démontrer on prête ce mot à son
fondateur ron hubbard décédé en 86
fonder sa propre religion est le
meilleur moyen de devenir millionnaire
une religion de science fiction dont le
contenu reste très flou c'est
précisément l'astuce chaque adepte
il trouve ce qu'il a envie d'y trouver
scientologie est peut-être en train de
brouiller des catégories de pensée qu'on
croyait bien établie pire qu'avant on
savait ce qu'était le religion le
politique l'économique la scientologie
c'est tout ça à la fois là qu'est ce qui
caractérise fondamentalement la
scientologie
finalement on pourrait dire que la
scientologie si c'est une religion c'est
à la fois la religion la marchandisation
de l'homme dire tout est à vendre
et puis c'est aussi une religion un peu
bizarre puisque finalement elle
considère que le problème dans l'homme
c'est l'homme exemple à paris d'une
séance de conditionnement d'un nouvel
adepte
j'ai appris par des intonations de voix
par des regards par des gestes physiques
à contrôler quelqu'un d'autre et à le
diriger là où je souhaite moi qui l'aïe
coma
je vais l'acquisition d'accord par cette
sorte de psychanalyse grossière la
scientologie se propose donc de révéler
la vraie nature de chacun avec le
concours de cet appareil décrété
infaillible d'électro m seulement les
découvertes successives des capacités
limitées de notre esprit ont un prix
tous les anciens adeptes affirmé avoir
laissé une grosse partie de leurs
revenus
dominique verdeilhan cette nouvelle
histoire concernant scientologie fait
plutôt tâche dans l'administration
judiciaire non oui des tomes d'un
volumineux dossier mystérieusement
disparu dans les 27 km de couloirs du
paju 6 de paris des scellés détruits
prématurément à marseille alors d'un
côté la possible négligence d'un juge
d'instruction de l'autre un greffier
pris d'une soudaine frénésie de faire le
ménage
rassurons-nous si la justice est parfois
accusé d'enterrer des affaires l égard
rarement des dossiers et des scellés
paris/marseille la coïncidence est
fâcheuse catalogué comme saic l'église
de scientologie n'est pas interdite par
les pouvoirs publics c'est donc vers
l'institution judiciaire que des
victimes des associations se tourner
pour obtenir une condamnation au tant
morale que pénales infiltration
pressions intimidations figurent parmi
les méthodes reprochées à la
scientologie
aujourd'hui face à cette disparition et
à cette destruction
on ne sait trop si la secte a le bras
long ou si il faudra désormais parler
d'une justice tête en l'air pourtant ce
que ça veut dire que l'action judiciaire
et est compromise dans le process
devrait bien se tenir à marseille le 20
septembre prochain mais la défense aura
beau jeu de plaider un dossier qui se
vident mais là encore il faut faire un
constat fâcher les procédures parisienne
et marseillaise sont vieilles de 10 en
un seul dossier celui de lyon est arrivé
à son terme la destruction des scellés à
marseille date de fin 81 18 vous l'avez
dit mais les magistrats ont attendu
début septembre pour la rendre publique
le procès de la scientologie pourrait
donc très bien se transformer en une
mise en cause des dysfonctionnements de
l'appareil judiciaire
merci d'un minute les magistrats du
tribunal de grande instance de montargis
dans le loiret ont à se prononcer pour
la première fois en france sur la notion
de responsabilité collective d'une
entreprise à savoir celle de la seita
la famille d'un fumeur décédé à la suite
d'un cancer demande en effet réparation
en reprochant au groupe de tabac
français un manque d'information sur les
dangers du tabac on sait aux états unis
déjà des procès ont eu lieu donnant tort
aux producteurs de tabac mais cette fois
la famille du fumeur a obtenu l'appui de
la caisse primaire d'assurance-maladie
du loiret compte-rendu agnès garder
marcel martin un procès historique
mais avant tout le combat d'une femme
celui de lucette gourlin son mari
richard est mort en janvier dernier
après trente ans de tabagisme qui l'ont
tué à petit feu doux puis s'ennuie
richard gourlin à fumer sa première
gauloise à l'âge de 12 ans un paquet par
jour puis 2d sans filtre les plus
nocives
survient alors le premier cancer du
poumon suivi d'un second un troisième
cancer oblige les médecins à lui amputer
de la langue
jamais il n'a arrêté de fumer après
11h30 d'intervention lorsqu'on a remis
mon mari dans sa chambre un mari qui
était que je ne reconnaissais pas mon
mari a mimé le geste de fumée il tenait
il faisait comme s'il tenait entre ses
doigts une cigarette et il tape aux
thèses comme si il avait de la cendre
qu'elle est tombée la cigarette était
devenu une drogue alors en 96 richard
gourlin décide de porter plainte contre
la seita motif il n'a pas été
suffisamment informés des risques liés
au tabagisme
c'est un enjeu de ce procès ce que nous
appelons la faute de la victime
bien entendu la ceta va dire et leur
réseau qu'un fumeur c'est que le tabac
est dangereux pour la santé n'est ce pas
mais d'abord il ne sait pas tout il sait
pas vraiment exactement les dangers on
dit par exemple qui perd sept ans
d'espérance de vie
pour la ces 35 ans c'est pas tout à fait
pareil quand même vous voyez le produit
est ce qu'il est il est connu pour être
ce qu'il est et si vous le consommez
vous le consommer avec un certain nombre
de risques
il devait assumer ces risques en
parfaite connaissance de cause et cette
connaissance qu'on l'avait avant même
que le message sanitaire ne souhaite
apposer sur les paquets lui c'est de
bourlens attend aujourd'hui réparation
elles demandent 3 millions de francs de
dommages et intérêts pour le préjudice
causé
ce procès dont le jugement a été mis en
délibéré au 8 décembre prochain est une
première en france
certes on est encore loin des actions
menées contre les grandes firmes
américaines
mais un procès similaire en allemand
ainsi qu'en espagne en ce moment même
laisse penser qu'un mouvement antitabac
est en train de prendre de l'ampleur en
europe
à l'assemblée nationale la commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur la corse a
entendu pendant près de trois heures ce
matin l'ancien préfet bernard bonnet de
corse l'addition à huit lots pas de
commentaire si ce n'est que monsieur
bonnet a déclaré avoir apprécié la
clarification que des échanges ont
permis
fin de citation des propos de monsieur
bonnet rentrée scolaire ça coince dur au
rectorat de paris depuis lundi plusieurs
centaines de parents d'élèves attendent
non sans quelque impatience de connaître
l'affectation de leurs enfants ils
seraient entre 4 et 500 ainsi laissés en
déshérence aujourd'hui dès 4 heures du
matin la file d'attenté se formaient
mais après l'impatience c'était la
colère reportages et les amarres goût
jean-françois hoffman et frédéric vion
vous et gardez pour laisser passer le
troisième jour de l'année scolaire
le rectorat de paris est pris d'assaut
par les parents et les élèves qui ne
sont toujours pas inscrits dans un
établissement et le tout finit par
monter je viens d'emménager à partie à 8
jours et ça fait trois jours consécutifs
que je fais là que moi c'est mon fils
aîné en seconde
voilà et lui l'attend son entrée en
seconde et c'est très grave
contrairement ce qu'on me dit ne ratez
une rentrée scolaire je suis là depuis
7h ce matin on vient nous dire qu'il ya
eu 60 personnes qui passent
c'est scandaleux scandaleux un simple
déménagement de province à paris ou même
d'un arrondissement à l'autre et trouver
une place au collège ou au lycée devient
un vrai casse tête
les élèves sont affectés par secteur
d'habitation pas de négociation possible
avec les chefs d'établissements
tout est centralisé au rectorat
nous y est
je trouve que déjà quand dans une
institution un service public où trouver
des recteurs qui vont pas confiance à
leurs principaux ou à leur proviseur sa
keynote quand même d'une mentalité qui
est un peu bizarroïdes
je crois d'éducation nationale c'est le
dernier bastion stalinien qui leur
administration en france selon le
rectorat les parents tentent d'obtenir
des dérogations pour aller dans un
établissement qui leur convient mieux
nous traitons aujourd'hui 300 dossiers
par jour
il y assure ses 300 une cinquantaine de
dossiers qui sont des emménagement
récent tous les autres dossiers sont des
demandes de révision d'affectation mais
là nous ne pouvons travailler qu'en
fonction des places disponibles
cela en tout cas resteront dehors il
leur faudra revenir demain le recteur a
n'ouvre ses portes que trois heures par
jour
en grèce le bilan provisoire du
tremblement de terre qui s'est
poursuivie depuis hier non loin
d'athènes est pour l'instant de 61 morts
mais il y aurait des dizaines de
personnes encore ensevelies qu pour
l'instant l'urgence des secours consiste
donc à retrouver ses dizaines de
personnes ensevelies sous les décombres
de plusieurs immeubles reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux à athènes à nice
vahramian et jacques gérard il est 15h
cet après midi pour les secouristes
français se mettre au travail
c'est comme s'il était sur le toit d'un
immeuble de six étages dessous peut-être
des vies ils ne savent pas les chiens ne
peuvent pas encore travaillé supérieur
creusé une cavité ça va permettre un
petit peu d'aérer les différentes
couches de gravats qu'hier et de faire
remonter les joueurs va faire
redescendre du chien dans le bain
qu'habiter et là ils vont à nouveau voir
s'il ya quelque chose
larry comex était une entreprise de des
clairions sept survivants ont déjà été
dégagés trois corps une quinzaine de
personnes seraient encore là dessous
et puis d'un seul coup il faut s'écarter
car ce qui reste de la cage d'ascenseur
de l'immeuble menace de s'effondrer dans
ce land à la demande ce qui a chuté
on dit qu'il faut continuer car sous
cette bâche deux hommes et une femme ont
été repérés il y a deux heures on ne les
voit pas 1 ou 10 octobre est qu'on parle
avec eux et nous disent que ça va
le mari de cette jeune femme et de ce
qu'on apprête à sauver elle n'a pas
accès aux mains ce trophée par les
secours mais elle a confiance
les secours sont très coopératif il
répond à nos questions ils nous traitent
humainement ils sont près de nous et
dans leurs mains il ya la vie de nos
maris le travail des secouristes
français pourrait prendre une dizaine
d'heures de l'autre côté auprès des
personnes repérées des turcs et des
suisses veulent eux aller plus vite en
moins de cinq semaines des successions
de tremblement terre viennent de toucher
la turquie puis la grèce dans qu'hier
soir en turquie le dernier bilan
officiel fait état de quinze mille 303
morts à l'origine de ces différents
séismes en turquie et en grèce
un même mouvement géologique
commentaires valérie fonio
dans une prière silencieux il espère à
nouveau entendre une voix le souffle
d'un vivant mais sans succès depuis ce
matin ces secouristes grecs n'ont sorti
que des corps sans vie des décombres de
cette usine des équipes de secours
françaises allemandes et notamment turcs
les ont rejoint la turquie l'émir
éditeur de la grèce qui n'a pourtant pas
hésité à envoyer de l'aide
je pense que c'est très bien pour nous
la première fois ce sont les grecs qui
nous vos idées la deuxième fois c'est à
nous turque de venir en grèce les aider
c'est à notre tour d'être solidaire unie
à présent dans la douleur cette nuit les
secouristes ont enchaîné intervention
sur intervention car chaque goutte d'or
en heure le bilan s'alourdit et les
enfants ne sont pas épargnés par cette
catastrophe
soixante et une personnes ont trouvé la
mort selon un bilan encore provisoire
cent vingt personnes ont été
hospitalisées 15 sont dans un état grave
dès ce matin l'armée grecque a distribué
des tentes à la population sans abri ou
préférent dormir dehors avec les
répliques les secousses qui continue
une zone au centre d'un affrontement des
plaques tectoniques arabe anatolienne et
eurasienne le séisme d'hier en grèce et
de la même origine que celui qui a
frappé la turquie mais 100 fois moins
important mais de grèce lui n'a problème
en cas c'est une faille d'une dizaine de
kilomètres de long et avec un glissement
que l'on estime pour l'instant à
quelques dizaines de centimètres mais ça
suffit pour que dans un rayon de 10 1
kilomètres si on puisse avoir des
dommages très importants
plus de 700 répliques ont eu lieu depuis
la première secousse l'alertent n'est
donc pas levé les autorités grecques
craignent un nouveau séisme 1 et sera
mien vous êtes en direct avec nous
depuis athènes vous étiez également avec
une équipe de france 2 en turquie alors
les intensités des décennies ce sont
différentes mais là et les réactions
sont elles semblable aux différentes en
grèce non le tremblement de terre dans
son intensité et en même temps dans les
dents les conséquences des dégâts
soyez bien moindre ici quoi qu'on ait
ressenti encore des répliques et jusqu'à
tout à l'heure même mais il n'y a pas de
polémique ici sur les secours comme il
pouvait y en avoir en turquie notamment
pour les secouristes français qui sont
déjà venus plusieurs fois et qui ont
l'habitude de travailler avec les grecs
et puis les lieux où il reste ce soir
encore des personnes ensevelies sont
très localisés tout comme les
destructions d'ailleurs en tout ici ce
sont 35 immeubles qui se sont effondrés
alors par exemple nous sommes ici à cinq
kilomètres de l'entreprise que vous avez
pu voir dans le reportage dans une zone
industrielle et le bâtiment vous pouvez
apercevoir derrière moi et bien est le
seul qui se soit effondré de cette façon
dans toute la zone industrielle alors ça
pose des questions comme en turquie
d'ailleurs sur les types de construction
et en grèce et bien des enquêtes ont
déjà été ouvertes par le parquet
d'athènes pour essayer d'établir des
responsabilités d'entrepreneurs ou
d'architecte alors si cette banlieue a
été touchée c'est parce qu'elle était
tout près de l'épicentre
mais dans la ville au centre ville
d'athènes qui a été épargnée par le
séisme et bien les habitants un peu
paniqués ont tout de même choisi soit de
partir vers les îles vers la côte donc
de s'éloigner des puissantes soit de
passer encore une nuit à la belle étoile
merci agnès l'indonésie ne veut pas qu
une force étrangère se déploie au timor
oriental et assure que depuis
l'instauration de la loi martiale le
calme revient une mission des nations
unies est arrivé à jakarta mais
apparemment en vain
les autorités n'ont pas changé d'avis de
son côté le président de la république
jacques chirac a sommé le conseil de
sécurité d'un sur unis d'assumer comme
il l'a fait au kosovo en créant la kfor
toutes ses responsabilités
et puis le haut commissariat aux
réfugiés de l'onu tente d'obtenir des
garanties de sécurité pour les dizaines
de milliers de personnes déplacées
une équipe de france 2 est actuellement
à darwin en australie où les victimes
auraient monseigneur bello prix nobel de
la paix lors d'une messe aujourd'hui a
exhorté la communauté internationale à
envoyer des troupes au timor oriental
pour faire cesser les violences
avec ou sans le consentement du
gouvernement indonésien reportage
isabelle bechler v tristan le braz
réfugia darwin au nord de l'australie
depuis d'hier l'évêque de 18 monseigneur
carlos bolo a concélébré ce soir sa 12e
- 124
pour les militaires et les organisations
humanitaires qui ont aidé les timorais à
décider de leur avenir que dieu leur
donne le courage et la force de
continuer pendant l'office il a été
question de dignité de compassion de
souffrance de curry l'évêque du nobel de
la paix a exhorté les dirigeants
occidentaux à intervenir pour mettre fin
au massacre et il ya bien peu de chances
que l'évêque soit entendu la petite
ville de darwin et ses 90 mille
habitants découvrent soudain
l'importance de l'enjeu
eux qui vivaient de pêche et de tourisme
il entrevoit la guerre c'est ici en
effet que l'armée australienne se
prépare pour son intervention de demain
il doit évacuer les 200 étrangers et les
160 qui m'aurait qui étaient encore
employées par les nations unies à 10 22
blindés de transport de troupes ont été
chargés sur un bâtiment de la marine
pour cela que deviendront les 1500
civils qui m'aurait réfugier sur le
terrain c'est l'inconnu les militaires
australiens ne seront pas assez nombreux
si l'armée indonésienne résident ou
provoquent de nouveaux massacres
c'est donc un constat d'échec et
d'impuissance de la mission de l'onu à
timor est ce si 350 hommes ne peuvent
pas se maintenir sur place on imagine
sans peine que la perspective d'une
intervention internationale de maintien
de la paix s'éloigne d'autant plus
d'abord l'indonésie s'y opposent
farouchement
ensuite au conseil de sécurité la chine
s'y opposerait et pour l'instant même
les etats unis se font tirer l'oreille
pour y participer
bonne nouvelle pour michelin son
résultat net est en progression de 17,3
pour cent quatre-vingt-dix-neuf mauvaise
nouvelle pour les salariés de michelin
le fabricant a décidé de réduire les
effectifs des usines en europe de 10%
sur trois ans c'est à dire la
suppression de 7500 postes
les bénéfices sont insuffisants 10 le
dirigeant de michelin commentaires luc
baziz
clermont ferrand ville but lieu symbole
de michelin ici cinq usines emploient
aujourd'hui plus de 16 mille personnes
soit presque la moitié du nombre
d'ouvriers qui travaillaient encore là
en 1981 aujourd'hui le pneumaticien
annonce un résultat net en progression
de plus de 20% sur le premier semestre
en même temps michelin déclare vouloir
améliorer sa compétitivité en europe de
20% sur trois ans et pour y parvenir le
manufacturier prévoient 7500
suppressions d'emplois sur la même
période
les implantations européennes sont
multiples pour le moment aucun incident
particulier n'a été encore désigné mais
la france sera certainement concernées
michelin veut augmenter ses parts de
marché et donc on est dans industrie de
coûts fixes on est dans l'industrie ou
les frais de personnel représentent une
part très importante à la production des
pneus est de plus en plus on a tendance
à produire dans les pays à bas coût de
main d'oeuvre
autre explication michelin un plan petit
à petit une machine révolutionnaire là
c'est troisième qui emploie six fois
moins d'ouvriers que dans une usine
classiques le système est directement
alimentés en matières premières et
retrache des pneus à l'autre bout de
quoi créer une peur sociale inquiète
sont inquiètes parce que la production
est plus importante avec moins de
personnes
la flexibilité de l'outil est beaucoup
plus importante donc c'est inquiétant
si on généralise et ça ça serait très
inquiétant même en 15 ans michelin a
déjà procédé à une dizaine de plans
sociaux
histoire de rester compétitif
publication d'un rapport sur la fraude
et l'évasion fiscale préparée par le
député communiste jean pierre brard
globalement on estime à 6000 milliards
de francs l'argent sale c'est à dire est
qu'il faut de logements notamment par la
drogue réinvesti dans différentes
banques dans le monde
c'est un pays membre de l'union
européenne le luxembourg qui occupe la
troisième place dans le secteur bancaire
des fonds d'investissement mais au
luxembourg on est discret et très peu
parlent de faire le ménage en cas de
yann genty et josette baltique
luxembourg au coeur de l'union
européenne un tout petit pays qui s'est
développée grâce à son activité bancaire
et financière aujourd'hui on compte deux
cent quinze établissements spécialisés
contre seulement 37 il y à peine 30 en
raison de ce succès un secret bancaire
strict et pas d'imposition à la source
sur les revenus de l'épargné
un véritable paradis bancaires décrit
comme tel par ce guide qui répertorie
les meilleures adresses à travers la
planète
résultat le grand duché attire
aujourd'hui les fraudeurs une situation
que très peu de luxembourgeois hausse
dénoncée beaucoup de gens ont cru que la
fraude fiscale était en fait un petit
délit tenteront de parler pâques était
un délit mineur non je pense qu'il ya
une certaine justice qui doit qu'il doit
jouer une justice fiscale aussi alors
pour redresser cela il faut à mon avis
changer les structures changer la
législation
une tâche qui s'annonce difficile il y a
deux ans des journalistes belges
s'étaient rendus dans une banque
luxembourgeoise
on leur avait à leur donner tous les
conseils pour fraude et discrètement
avec un chèque pour moi pour qu'on voit
là c'est à présent si vous le transférer
mais le luxembourg n'est pas un cas
isolé en europe 11 paradis fiscaux sont
clairement identifiés beaucoup plus dans
le reste du monde
bahamas costa rica aux bermudes toute
une série de pays que certains
voudraient sanctionner les pays de
l'union européenne ont fourni environ
800 millions de dollars d aide aux
bahamas pour financer les
infrastructures de base
il ya quelque chose d' immoral et
d'anormal en même temps ce pays
accueil de l'argent d'origine incertaine
qui échappe à ses devoirs et nous
l'aiderons voyait qu'il ya quelque chose
qui ne va pas autre proposition avancée
pour combattre la fraude et l'évasion
fiscale la publication officielle d'une
liste des principaux pays incriminés
après une nuit de fête au larzac josé
bové le syndicaliste de la confédération
paysanne était aujourd'hui à paris une
entend solliciter le premier ministre et
le président de la république pour
évoquer avec eux la mondialisation et
l'organisation mondiale du commerce mais
aussi la question de la responsabilité
politique des juges a dit
c'est mauvais d'ailleurs cet après midi
à millau dans l'aveyron des militants de
la confédération paysanne se sont
enchaînés aux grilles du tribunal pour
protester contre ce qu'ils appellent
l'acharnement des juges et la mise en
examen de plusieurs de leurs camarades
la réunion du bureau politique du rpr
tenu aujourd'hui à paris confirme que le
mouvement gaulliste est devenu à sa
manière un mouvement pluriel pour
l'élection du président du rpr qui
s'achèvera en décembre il y a déjà
plusieurs candidats et chacun estime que
c'est un bon signe pour la vie
démocratique du rpr reportage carole
caumont et luc bachofen nicolas sarkozy
se prépare à traverser des semaines
difficiles
il n'est pas encore officiellement
candidat mais la bataille pour la
présidence du rpr s'annonce rude et le
calendrier s'accélère
il y a deux jours françois fillon un
proche de philippe séguin annonçait sa
candidature il ya aujourd'hui plusieurs
lignes politiques qui s'affrontent je
crois que nous devons faire trancher
cette question par les militants et la
seule façon de la faire trancher c'est
l'élection du président et voilà qu'un
nom fait désormais l'objet de toutes les
attentions celui du sénateur jean paul
delevoye
inconnu du public comme des militants il
aurait pourtant les faveurs de jacques
chirac
il ne dévoilera ses intentions que la
semaine prochaine mais se présente déjà
comme une alternative à nicolas sarkozy
je crois qu'il n'y a pas d'opposition de
personnes il a simplement les volontés
exprimées par les uns et par les jours
de redonner du souffle à la pensée
gaulliste est de permettre à la grèce de
pouvoir s'exprimer
l'elysée qui semble suivre de près la
bataille en cours au rpr il y à quelques
heures renaud muselier autres candidats
déclarés
sa fiche est à saint pierre et miquelon
au côté de jacques et bernadette chirac
ce matin la perspective d'une campagne
animée le mettait plutôt de bonne humeur
mais en était
il y en a quand même ça commence à
assortir vois que le débat est en train
de s'engager sincèrement le bureau
politique du rpr a défini aujourd'hui
les modalités d'organisation de
l'élection est déjà l'ambiance
s'alourdit
certains craignent que nicolas sarkozy
aujourd'hui à la tête du parti ne soit
favorisé cours de la campagne nicolas
sarkozy qui pour l'instant a choisi de
rester silencieux c'est que la campagne
sera longue
le prochain président du rpr sera élu
par les militants début décembre
remise aujourd'hui au premier ministre
un rapport de madame dominique gillot
sur les propositions visant à renforcer
la parité désormais inscrit dans la
constitution parité hommes femmes dans
la vie publique avec en particulier un
pourcentage minimum de candidatures
féminines pour les scrutins de liste du
sport du football la leçon est plutôt
rude les champions du monde ont
longtemps un peu bafouillé leur football
de rêve de l'année dernière avant de
l'emporter finalement 3-2 il en gagné
c'était l'essentiel commentaires
christophe du chien si tout avait
fonctionné comme tout doit normalement
fonctionné les français auraient débuté
la rencontre dans la joie et la bonne
humeur seulement après cinq minutes de
match youri djorkaeff manque d' adresse
et rate l'occasion d'ouvrir le score
dans la foulée les blancs perdre
bêtement le ballon et les arméniens
contre attaque
mika qu on se retrouve seul à seul avec
fabien barthez et mika clients
contrairement à djorkaeff envoie le
ballon au fond des filets les champions
du monde
son nom est un zéro pour une mauvaise
surprise c'est une mauvaise surprise
un quart d'heure de jeu une sympathique
réaction française mais le tir de zidane
passe de peu à côté
à quelques secondes du repos un viril
défenseur arménien commettent une faute
sur laurent blanc
et c'est un penalty qui va sauver la mi
temps inquiète en défonçant djorkaeff
qui revendique haut et fort son
ascendance arménie égalise 1 partout à
la mi-temps en deuxième période
zinédine zidane que l'on a déjà connu
dans le rôle du sauveur va donner l
avantage aux français échouent du gauche
il très heureux de zad
un peu plus tard djorkaeff lens lille
dans la seconde qui finit pas rassuré
tout son monde en inscrivant le
troisième but tricolore
ce but était pas trop bien au contraire
car les français finissent comme ils ont
commencé en encaissant un but idiot sur
un penalty concédé suite à une
mésentente barthez lizarazu les
arméniens marque score final 3 à 2 pour
la france qui avait impérativement
besoin d'une victoire et c'est fait pour
le reste il n'y a pas de quoi être fier
et pour se qualifier craquer français
gagne 9 octobre contre l'iran un
contrôle l'islande et puis le l'autre
résultat dans le même groupe pour l'euro
2000 la russie a battu andorre
difficilement 2 1 du tennis avec des
internationaux de flushing meadow à new
york la nuit dernière cédric pioline
s'est qualifié pour les quarts de finale
il a battu l'allemand tommy haas et en
quart de finale il rencontrera le
brésilien gustavo kuerten et puis il y
aura donc un second français en quarts
de finale avec nicolas escudé côté
féminin mary pierce
je vous le rappelle est également en
quarts de finale enfin notez que c'est
john mcenroe qui vient d'être nommé au
poste de capitaine de l'équipe
américaine de coupe davis du cinéma avec
un très beau film aujourd'hui sur les
écrans
c'est quoi la vie de françois dupeyron
la question est ambitieuse mais elle
symbolise bien l'histoire de trois
hommes trois générations où l'on
retrouve l'actualité d'ailleurs c'est à
dire le malaise paysan l'endettement est
le maintien au pays le film a été tourné
près de millau dans l'aveyron une région
de josé bové dans le film c'est quoi la
vie le grand père c'est jacques dufilho
le père jean pierre darroussin est le
plus jeune sept éric caravaca
présentation pascal deschamps et gilbert
usant du coup je passe ma vie ici un
regard des filets les jours tous les
jours la même chose c'est sa vive
nicolas et petit fils et fils de paysan
et journée entière de travail pour des
revenus de misère des dettes jusqu'au
cou sans oublier la vache folle
alors nicolas s'interroge sur ce qu'il
veut vraiment faire de sa vie françois
dupeyron a attendu son troisième film
pour oser parler d'un monde qu'il
connaît bien mes parents est agriculteur
et comme le personnage je me suis posé
plusieurs fois la question est-ce que je
reste parce que je pars un george martin
je bougeais je peux rester ici avec des
oeillères je veux voir plus loin
le fait de partir d'être parti de chez
moi 1 a laissé chez moi une cicatrice
une douleur et je crois que c'est cette
douleur là qui a fait que j'ai toujours
repousser le moment de le faire
[ __ ] 6h10 non j'aurais pas dormi
beaucoup c'est tout vu ou tu vas changer
le soleil te dis bonjour c'est comme ça
que tu lui réponds regard de tous mais
j'aime sortir du ventre de sa mère je
suis partie à la campagne si
pendant quelque temps encore trois
semaines pour poursuivre la ville la
campagne
voilà j'ai aidé un agriculteur dans ses
tâches quotidiennes et qu'est ce qui
vous a le plus frappé au moment de cette
expérience d'être en semaine c'est déjà
les journées qui finissent parce que
dans les villes la lumière électrique
prend le relais françois dupeyron nous
apprend à regarder autrement le monde
paysan
mais s'il a quitté la terre pour faire
du cinéma son héros lui décidera de
rester comme un hommage à peine voilée
la petit cadeau pour achever ce journal
souvenirs souvenirs cet étang 68 les
beatles apparaissait dans un film
intitulé yellow submarine sénat en voir
un extrait car une nouvelle version
numérique était présentée aujourd'hui à
paris pour l'occasion le roster que
voici été transformé en sous marin jaune
et nous pensons enfin vers quelle fut la
version française
voilà et puis il ya la sortie aussi du
d'un disque avec notamment il est le
seul marine économiques bipe qui vient
de sortir pour l'occasion c'est et 1,68
nous arrivons à la fin de ce journal je
vous rappelle trois informations que
nous avons développées tout d'abord
concernant des scellés d'instruction de
concernant l'instruction
une affaire de l'église de scientologie
qui ont été détruits à marseille un an
après la disparition de certains
éléments d'une information judiciaire
concernant aussi les scientologues et il
avait dissous la garde des sceaux
diligente une enquête administrative
le bilan provisoire toujours du séisme à
athènes 61 morts et des dizaines de
personnes encore ensevelies et secours
continuent et puis enfin cette dernière
information concerne timor on vient
d'apprendre que 20 découvert que 100
personnes avaient été assassinées dans
la paroisse de soyaux timor donc trois
religieux formation qui vient de
parvenir donc sur ce qui se passe en ce
moment même au timor la météo c'est dans
quelques instants avec isabelle martinet
puis last hit avec gérard klein suivi de
jean luc delarue pour la soirée continue
dans un ca se discute qui seront
consacrés aux tentations de suicide chez
les adolescents à 0 heures 50 le journal
de laurence ostolaza puis la première du
nouveau magazine de philippe lefait des
mots de minuit avec notamment l'écrivain
portugais antonio lobo antunes s et
sandrine bonnaire à 7h50 demain
françoise laborde recevra bertrand
delanoë le président du groupe
socialiste au conseil de paris
et puis à 13h vous trouverez ici même
carole gaessler rachid arhab et fabrice
luchini à demain 20h bon soir merci